alright so the heading is in next laws
without a bra the days of 26th of March
and let's recall what is this ok so
index laws you may remember we dealt
with index laws but I said laws that's
what the best word for what these things
are right
I call them shortcuts shortcuts and we
elect five of them we left five of them
it was the whole idea that you know when
you multiply numbers over and over again
that's what you used this seems for
right but if you can understand how to
work just with indices and not have to
worry about ah it's about multiplication
you could do things so much faster
okay so examples that we looked at if I
said too cute right and I multiplied it
by two through the power of five we're
gonna take these two numbers the reason
I can actually put these together is
because they have the same well this
number here we have a name for this
stuff that starts of the beads in order
meant by anything the base very good
semesters of a bottom okay so you got
the bases they're the same so you put as
up as we said the middle numbers which
also have a name where they call it they
got a few different things right we
could say yeah powers we can say indices
we're gonna say they're really super
take the cord over you experiments okay
one same thing okay we can't add them
together so this is to the power of
three plus five which of course is 28
okay
okay now excuse me I've done everything
I need to hear we can double check it we
can verify by remembering what these
powers mean okay and then we can see
whether we need to do that so two cubes
what's a destroy cut what's an
abbreviation off somebody hasn't said
anything yeah but no yeah great - why -
that's that's too cute right there okay
in the same way 2 to the power 5 it's
gonna be fun 5 done so I've written all
the twos out I said where I've put
expanded it and you can see I've got 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 2 to the 8th ok happy with
that it's not make sense so we let this
shortcut that you can add the powers
those with the only shortcut that was
just the first one okay can someone give
me another one
we're very similar to this one but maybe
even reverse are you take it let's try
this one today this is a bit sticky the
bit sticky but I think you guys can
handle it okay before I do anything to
it any operations there's something is a
number that's hiding there haven't
written it but it's really there anyone
any takers what's hiding yeah okay good
so these three is really this is one of
them so it's really three the power of
one okay so I'm dividing instead of what
to play so what's the shortcut I can use
here Brendon good okay I'm gonna instead
of adding instead of adding I'm going to
subtract 0 3 look I have 4 minus 1 so
speak users okay good now we had a
couple of other ones right right
and just to remind you okay if I take
Eddie now let's go back to 2
and raise it to the power of zero that
was a bit weird looks like multiply it
by itself
zero times but we looked at we thought
about it what was the conclusion we drew
yeah it's one fantastic
okay and a very similar one if I have a
zero not in the power but at the base 5
0 ^ anything two three four five six
hundred okay what's it going to be equal
to
yeah zero good because it's just zero
two zero two zero two zero and it never
amount to anything
poor guy okay one last law that we
learned why this one is 1
okay I'm gonna I should go back here so
your previous notes on it it's still it
makes sense you can watch a video it
still doesn't make sense you can ask me
do for us for it alright last one you
have enough why'd you have a question
yep yeah great okay so let's take that
exact example so here I've got a number
squared right and I will raise that
whole thing to another power okay maybe
for you I'd say seven what do I do with
these numbers I added here I subtracted
so does a seventy forget someone who
hasn't contributed yet for the good yeah
okay so dusty I had it I subtracted now
these guys right there should be five to
the power of Allah to 14 because it's
two by seven right so five subtract 14
what that's gonna be a pretty big number
okay that's one secret now all this is
with actual numbers but where we going
to progress to in this exercise is using
these shortcuts with algebra right using
these shortcuts with algebra let's give
these a go and remember these are things
that we're familiar with but we just
want to get really really super
comfortable weird and really quick
happen just like tying your shoelaces
okay make it automatic this one here
right I don't know what B is it's it's
algebra isn't it
okay but that doesn't mean I can't
understand it and work with it that's
the whole point even though I've got
these laws here planted numbers this
these beans here are also numbers
adjusted over there okay so a lot supply
so which shortcut am I going to use yeah
Rachel fantastic it's the first one
because it's multi-patient
right so when you multiply it on this
same base but different indices you add
their innocence together literacy so
that's going to be B ^ they you can't do
it all in one hit but I think it's
helpful if you write it out as 4 plus 10
plus 2 that's more instructive to you
and to me to show that you know where
that 16 comes from right it's because I
added I'm adding all those numbers okay
now in the same way let's have a got
this now I've chosen this one number one
because it's division number two it's a
bit trickier cuz this this must stop in
there okay now when we were having a
look at terms yesterday day before
anyway previously you see I've gotten up
is here so I'm gonna deal with the
numbers first right I've got 18 divided
by 6 those tables 18 divided by 6 89 by
6 is 3 right so I'll write down a three
so I've dealt with the numbers them and
then I left with these unknowns
Peter power 7 P to power 3 and up to
mine so which would shock up yeah hold
on
it's the question with shotcut with shut
up okay be really familiar with them
perfect okay so now what do I do
okay now I'm going to cross out some of
them but not all of them and I'll use
the shortcut to know how many okay so
it's not like this P just disappears
with this P disappears and it becomes ^
7 2003 okay I'm dealing with numbers
first done and now dealing with the
printables okay right now just to be a
bit of an instructive write that for
that 4 is 7 minus 3 7 take away 3 right
because of this shortcut that we learned
before okay of course if you wanted to
you could write out the 7 PT and three
P's here and they'd cancel now that'll
take forever
use a shortcut if you can